[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 2
février
des bijoux des tableaux ou encore des
lettres anciennes faire évaluer ses
objets de valeur peut être utile et
compliqué parfois un hôtel de ventes aux
enchères parisien s'est délocalisé jeudi
à versailles
ses adversaires le voient disparaître
certains sont persuadés qu'il a encore
un avenir le ps débute sa campagne en
vue du congrès du mois d'avril pour
évoquer l'avenir du parti socialiste
notamment dans les yvelines nous
recevrons son co secrétaire
départemental jean claude husson dans le
reste de l'actualité retour sur la
mobilisation des élus locaux pour une
métropole du grand paris régional ou
encore la mobilisation des ehpad
c'était mardi faire expertiser
gratuitement ses trésors de famille
cette opération à l'initiative d'une
maison de ventes aux enchères parisienne
s'est déroulée hier jeudi à versailles
les particuliers pouvait emmener leurs
objets et repartir avec un conseil une
estimation encore les laisser en dépôt
pour qu'il soit vendu ensuite reportage
d'aurélie rose a valeur de ces objets
c'est l'ancienneté des bijoux des
tableaux ou encore des lettres anciennes
scrutés par l'oeil avisé de commissaire
priseur plusieurs fois dans l'année un
hôtel des ventes aux enchères parisien
délocalise son activité à versailles le
temps d'une journée pour venir à la
rencontre des particuliers toi il
souhaite seulement une estimation pour
savoir combien
une raisons d'assurance ou le partage
soit et souhaite lui confier à mort et
dans ces cas-là il le laisse ici en
dépôt et nous le vendre à paris comme
estimations j'aurais tendance à mettre
dans les 800 à 1200 qui est une
estimation raisonnable je trouve que
c'est très bien parce que
beaucoup de jolies choses à versailles
ça évite d'aller à paris on a
une estimation qui est certainement
fiable puisque une estimation cette
opération également pour but d'en
apprendre plus sur les objets apporté
des trésors de famille qui remonte pour
certains au milieu du 19e siècle
j'ai un livre très anciens l'a donc à
raconter un petit peu son histoire et et
comme il est à moitié manuscrit il est
relié à moitié manuscrits donc elle m'a
un petit peu expliquer à quoi ça
correspond des autographes aussi des
autographes du second empire
chaque objet est précieux il suffit
qu'il soit rare quelle que soit la
matière dans laquelle il est fait donc
un tableau peut être aussi précieux
qu'un via les objets collectés lors de
cette journée des expertises seront mis
en vente en mars
d'autres opérations de ce type auront
lieu dans les prochains mois à
versailles
c'est un sujet sensible pour les
yvelines et notamment pour le sud du
département la question de la mobilité
et des transports alors que les annonces
du gouvernement se font toujours
attendre sur le calendrier du grand
paris express et la ligne 18 le maire de
magny les hameaux bertrand guillon
demande lui la tenue d'une conférence
territoriale sur ces problématiques et
envoyé un courrier en ce sens à
l'adresse de nombreux élus du territoire
dont valérie pécresse la présidente ait
l'air de la région objectif réfléchir à
des solutions pour le court terme sans
attendre la mise en place des grands
chantiers au lait coûte ça fait quarante
années qu'on évoque des différents
sujets dans le cadre des différents
plans qu'on nous demande de constituer
dans nos collectivités avec l'état
comptera développement territorial par
exemple et depuis 40 ans on pose des
solutions qui sont parfois des solutions
simples l'arrêt du ter qui vient de
chartres rambouillet à 50 ans du lean
directement par exemple le prolongement
de la ligne c du rer jusqu'à rambouillet
et maintenant depuis dix ans ne parle
plus que de cette ligne 18 qui
n'arrivera de toute façon que vers 2024
voire 2030 voire au delà
mais en attendant qu'est ce qu'on fait
et la question des transports nous
allons l'évoqué notamment avec notre
invité pour cette émission jean claude
husson bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
maire rhdp
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines excusez moi
vous connaissez bien aussi berton lyon
forcément l'un de nos collègues du monde
rural peut être que vous avez d'ailleurs
reçu ce courrier qu'il a envoyé je ne
sais pas à différents élus cette
problématique des transports forcément à
vous concerne aussi est ce que vous
seriez aussi vous favorable du coup à
une conférence sur ce sujet dans le
département des yvelines pour le sud
yvelines sur sur les transports oui
pourquoi pas parce qu'il ya plusieurs
problématiques qui se posent sur le
département il ya la ligne n'en parle
bertrand nous avons aussi la
problématique des zones très rurales du
département on a vu des lignes qui ont
accéléré les cadences et c'est une bonne
chose pour les habitants mais en même
temps donc on a fait des lignes express
pour ça mais en même temps on a
abandonné des villages où les bus ne
passe plus c'est le cas par exemple de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines est-ce que
vous avez des difficultés nous on avait
un déficit et par l'accélération
c'est un express passe parce interne ou
par contre les villages qui sont aux
alentours je peux citer l'envié
rochefort ce que je connais bien les
maires on a discuté de ces sujets là bus
passe le but ça passe à côté de chez eux
et ne s'arrête plus donc il ya une
problématique de transport pour les
habitants de la grande couronne qui doit
être traité et pourquoi pas faire cette
conférence sur les transports et puis y
est grande actualité qui ne cesse de
faire la une des médias c'est le grand
paris express la ligne 18 pour le
département des yvelines
comment vous regardez ça vous
concrètement puisque vous n'êtes pas
directement jamais dire concernés par
cette ligne elle ne passerait pas très
proche de chez vous est ce que c'est
c'est un éventuel retard comme le laisse
entendre le gouvernement pour la r18 est
ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
inquiète vous en tant que maire de
saint-arnaud si les investissements sont
concentrées sur ses lignes et qu'on
oublie les autres territoires ruraux
dont je viens de parler ça peut être
d'un kg études forte des habitants de
dérapage du coût de ces lignes je crois
qu'à doubler aujourd'hui la progression
de 6 38 milliards d'euros contre 19 il
ya sept ans c'est ça qui vous inquiètent
principalement c'est de se dire qu'il
aura plus d'argent pour les autres autre
investissement évidemment il faut
répartir les investissements de
transport sur l'ensemble des habitants
plus vous éloignez vous vous éloignez de
paris plus vous avez des habitants aux
conditions modestes qui passe une heure
trente voire deux heures à l'est pour
aller travailler
c'est des conditions de travail qui sont
quand même extrêmement difficiles
imposées les consulter sur des sujets
comme ça par exemple même si vous n'êtes
pas je le disais encore une fois
concerné directement par cette ligne
elle ne passe pas dans le sud yvelines
concrètement est ce que vous êtes tout
de même concertés pour éventuellement
créer des liens entre entre votre ville
et puis la ligne 18
alors en ce qui concerne vraiment la
pointe sud des yvelines qui est le
canton de rambouillet où
l'intercommunalité rambouillet
territoire rambouillet territoire a pris
la compétence transport et donc nous
sommes en train de définir tous les
jeudis à tous les élus du territoire
sommes en train de définir notre projet
de territoire et le transport ont fait
partie donc nous sommes en cours cette
année en 2018 de définition de nos
souhaits volonté demande auprès de
france mobilité en ce qui concerne le
transport sur le sujet divise alors
bertrand lyon vous le connaissez en
qualité d'élue locale comme vous mais
aussi parce que vous avez appartenu
pendant longtemps aux mêmes partis tous
les deux le parti socialiste utilise le
passé puisque lui a quitté le ps
lorraine avant il a rejoint génération
le mouvement de benoît hamon
est ce que la question s'est posée pour
vous aussi un temps de quitter le ps
pour rejoindre un autre mouvement que ce
soit génération la république en marche
autres est ce que vous y avez pensé vous
aussi pas du tout pas du tout parce que
j'ai une équipe municipale qui s'est
construite sur un contrat en 2014
pas du tout parce que j'ai porté les
couleurs du parti socialiste pendant les
législatives et pas du tout parce qu'ils
aient encore nombre de militants au
parti avec lesquels je souhaite
travailler justement pour parler les
militants au sein du ps local
récemment il ya une centaine de membres
de cadres du ps 78 qui a quitté le ps
pour rejoindre génération combien vous
vous êtes devenu co secrétaire
départemental depuis vous êtes 4 à la
tête du ps 78 aces à combien vous êtes
concrètement aujourd'hui au sein du ps
78 en rappelant malheureusement pour
vous mais c'est la réalité que vous
n'avez plus de conseillers
départementaux vous n'avez pas de
députés pas de sénateur
combien vous êtes de militants encore
aujourd'hui au sein du ps 78 aujourd'hui
c'est le congrès qui va nous faire
permettre de faire les comptes de voir
ce qu'ils renouvellent ou ne
renouvellent pas leurs cotisations donc
le dernier chiffre que nous avons c'est
1326 pas nécessairement à jour de leurs
cotisations et on fera les comptes à la
fin du congrès mais le ps soit 118 n'est
pas mort c'est la question qu'on se pose
généralement il vit encore il ya encore
des choses qui se passent sur le
territoire il est bien vivant ça je vous
rassure et j'en suis la preuve je suis
là devant vous nous sommes quatre
secrétaires collégiaux à organiser
administrativement la fédération des
yvelines
il y a un bureau fédéral issus du
dernier congrès qui continue à se réunir
et qui accélère son rythme de réunions
pour préparer le concret donc une
réunion par semaine
et puis un conseil fédéral qui rassemble
plus largement qui se réunit deux fois
par mois
donc tout ça fonctionne on est en train
de préparer notre congrès le congrès
vous aurez du coup à aux mandarines
normalement un nouveau secrétaire
départemental complètement fédéral ou et
quels étaient les objectifs après ces
deux c'est de préparer
les élections européennes localement se
préparer les municipales et si de
rencontrer certaines villes bien sûr
c'est complètement l'objectif du parti
alors les européennes là il ya des
décisions éminemment nationale pour la
constitution de la liste
par contre la préparation des
municipales est évidemment un enjeu
surtout après les résultats difficiles
de 2014 aujourd'hui le la survie du ps
est ce que cela passe aussi par ce
congrès finalement si tout se passe bien
vous aurez une base pour reconstruire et
si c'est un congrès comme on en connaît
parfois au sein du ps très très
compliqué ça risque j'imagine de porter
un coup fatal au à votre parti c'est
comme ça qu'il faut envisager les choses
on pourrait le penser mais en fait les
choses sont sereines tel que je le vois
à l'intérieur du parti nous avons quatre
candidats pour le secrétariat national
le dernier qu'on fait des conseil
fédéral que auquel j'ai assisté
inquiéter le premier depuis le départ
des 100 j'ai vu une forme de débat
serein avec des gens qui avaient plaisir
à se retrouver ça c'est rassurant ça
permet de mettre les choses au clair
finalement complètement le en fait
l'enjeu du congrès ça va être de
redéfinir ou de se reposer la question
sur qui nous sommes et qu'est ce qu'on
veut pour le pays donc on va re débattre
sur ces sujets là parce qu'il ya eu
c'est vrai un certain nombre de
tiraillements sur la fin du dernier
quinquennat
le congrès va sur toute la rive y est ça
mais je n'ai pas d'inquiétude sur la
pérennité du parti les militants sont là
il ya une organisation qui est là la
question c'est qu'est ce qu'on veut
qu'est ce que veulent les militants
parce que le langer du congrès aussi
c'est de re débattre et de recréer du
lien entre les militants et le parti au
niveau national
encore une question sur ses sur ses
membres ses cadres locaux qui ont quitté
le parti
ils ont eu des mots très durs dans un
communiqué de presse peut être un avis
que partage des militants encore
actuelle du ps ils ont dit le ps n'est
plus en mai
d'être le parti autour duquel la gauche
pourra se reconstruire mais il dit
surtout que le ps cdh et rené
renoncement de la trahison un
fonctionnement archaïque
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à
toutes ces attaques
quand je vois les jeunes qui restent
avec nous je suis absolument pas inquiet
de l'avenir du parti d'abord il n'ya pas
que des cards les sens et pas que des
cadres qui sont partis ça c'est le
premier point est le deuxième il ya un
seul mercier partie d'ailleurs voilà il
ya un deuxième wii tout à faire trop ou
lyon qu'on a vu c'est ça dans le dos
ligne et un deuxième point important
c'est que des personnes qui étaient
proches de benoît reste au parti c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait le choix inverse qui
est la fidélité au parti socialiste et
au débat au sein du parti socialiste que
j'ai vraiment je n'ai pas d'inquiétude
sur ce qui va se passer
il va y avoir une rénovation après c'est
le débat du concret c'est ça qui va être
intéressant
il ya quatre propositions pour le
secrétariat national
mais la volonté réelle c'est évidemment
de reconstruire du débat et de travail
anses justement très rapidement la
question sur ce congrès avec avec quatre
candidats en lice emmanuel maurel luc
carvounas olivier faur stéphane le foll
votre candidat avoue ses olives effort
très rapidement pourquoi olivier faure
et pas un autre
qu'est-ce qui sait celui qui est plus en
capacité de rassembler les socialistes
quelles que soient les origines ou les
tendances
on le voit à l'image à l'assemblée
nationale jean claude husson rester avec
nous on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité de la semaine
les semaines passent les rassemblements
se multiplient les annonces officielles
elles se font toujours attendre sur la
métropole du grand paris alors pour
continuer à se faire entendre les
présidents des départements d'île de
france se sont réunis une nouvelle fois
mercredi à la scène musicale à boulogne
billancourt ils répètent leur message
pas de suppression des départements est
une métropole à l'échelle de la région
les détails avec ce reportage
même lieu même et lui même message le
jeu des sept erreurs en presque parfait
pour ses discours à deux semaines
d'intervalle
qui sera capable de faire à notre place
tout ce que nous réalisons pourquoi
détruire ce qui marche pour rafistoler
ce qui ne marche pas
les élus d'ile-de-france ne lâchent pas
leur vision du grand paris alors que les
annonces du gouvernement se font
toujours attendre
pour eux la réforme de la métropole ne
peut entraîner la suppression des
départements et doit s'élargir à toute
la région un enjeu qu'il estime crucial
pour le développement des territoires
des co-investissements ne se feront pas
avoir six ou dans la grande couronne se
feront priorité c'est ce qu'on appelle
la petite couronne la petite ceinture et
on peut pas avoir au sein de
l'ile-de-france un nouveau périphérique
la grande couronne dont nous faisons
partie est une évidence et une nécessité
aujourd'hui pour un équilibre ça nous
permettrait également d'éviter les mille
feuilles qui sont aujourd'hui difficiles
à comprendre
invité d'honneur du rassemblement 500
élus locaux et des représentants de la
société civile
moi la notion des départements me parle
la notion de la région me parle la
notion de métropole me parle beaucoup
moins chefs d'entreprises responsables
d'associations partenaires sociaux ils
ont tous justifier l'importance du
département est tenté de mettre la
pression pour l'avenir et là on a voulu
que des chefs d'entreprise et
responsables associatifs et travailleurs
sociaux
bref qu'une celles et ceux qui savent
l'indispensable nécessité du département
puisse s'exprimer
je crois qu'ils ont fait avec leurs mots
et surtout avec leur exemple prochaine
action des départements d'île de france
mercredi 7 février avec une fermeture
des services publics
les décisions du gouvernement sont elles
attendues une semaine plus tard jean
claude husson ce sujet de la métropole
du grand paris semble dépasser les
clivages politiques il y à même le
président communistes du département du
val de marne qui très investi dans dans
le sujet quelle est votre position à
vous est ce que vous partagez la
position des présidents par exemple l
ère des hauts-de-seine des yvelines sur
cette métropole qui doit être élargie à
la région pour pour par exemple que
st-arnaud en fasse partie
il ya je pense à la taxe foncière avec
la petite ligne en bas où on cotise tout
en n'étant pas dans le grand paris c'est
pour ces jeux j'hésitais incroyable mais
oui un grand paris on est quelqu'un
parler du millefeuille
on a essayé de simplifier on se retrouve
avec le grand paris
moi cette le croirez pas je crois oui il
faut la région peut gérer ce niveau
il ya les tribus les compétences dont
elle a besoin pour gérer l'ensemble de
la région ile de france je pense que
c'est ce qu'il faut faire par contre je
précise parce que derrière il peut y
avoir des intentions des uns et des
autres je reste défavorable à la fusion
des yvelines oui c'est un des sujets
local important mais il ya aujourd'hui
devenu presque secondaire puisque si la
métropole n'est pas large et à la région
ce qui est sûr ce qu'il n'y aura pas de
fusion
qu'est ce que les deux entités seront
pas dans la même dans la même collective
vois bien pourquoi certains voudraient
que élargira la région pourquoi ensuite
fusionner les départements ce qui est
pas tout à fait mon choix en tout cas
mon avis on va passer à un autre sujet
d'actualité cette semaine les
différentes mobilisations sociales mardi
personnel des ehpad et retraités
manifesté pour dénoncer le manque de
moyens pour les uns et le matraquage
fiscal pour les autres retour sur cette
journée de manifestation sur des images
de patrick jacques de dixmude et quentin
le frère de rassemblement deux lieux
différents mais une seule et même cible
retraités et personnels d pad dénonce la
politique du gouvernement
mouvement principal celui des maisons de
retraite partout en france et dans les
yvelines
le mouvement est inédit pour le secteur
à l'appel de l'ensemble des syndicats et
des directeurs d'établissement pour
réclamer notamment une hausse des
effectifs
le problème c'est qu'on ne réussit même
pas à respecter le rythme des résidents
et surtout à respecter leur autonomie ce
qui fait qu'on fait des fois des choses
à leur place parce qu'on peut pas les on
peut pas prendre le temps pour les aider
on ressent bien les familles ce qu'elles
disent
se fait vite il ya aussi les toilettes
les bains qui sont peut-être pas donner
forcément régulièrement et voudront
donner beaucoup plus est ne peuvent
comme des douches face à une dégradation
quand même au niveau de la prise en
charge de la personne âgée
plus tôt dans la journée ce sont les
retraités qui se sont réunis devant la
préfecture à versailles hausse de la csg
gel des pensions baisse des apl la
colère et variés contre le gouvernement
et pour la défense du porte-monnaie de
pouvoir d'achat diminue d'année en année
depuis au moins un sport enfin deux de
plus que moi j'ai pris ma retraite je
sais que mon pouvoir d'achat a diminué
donc je trouve que c'est pas juste et
que c'est toujours la même chose que les
actionnaires s'enrichissent emmanuel
macron président des riches l'argument
social est désormais rodée et pourrait
être encore développé jeudi avec une
nouvelle manifestation prévue
cette fois ci contre la réforme du bac
et la nouvelle plateforme parcours sup
jean claude husson les mobilisations se
multiplient un peu de tous les côtés les
agents pénitentiaires les ehpad les
hôpitaux les étudiants on va le voir
aussi dans quelques instants ce que vous
pensez qu'on a à l'aube d'un mouvement
social d'ampleur en france c'est
possible ça je peux pas deviner mais en
tout cas on voit bien que les français
commencent à découvrir la réalité de la
politique libérale du gouvernement moi
je tiens réagir sur ce qu'a dit à
monsieur on ne peut même plus respecter
l'autonomie des personnes âgées terre
que ne les laissant pas faire ce
qu'elles sont capables de faire elles
mêmes elles perdent encore plus
rapidement leur autonomie on est
vraiment dans un problème de dignité de
la personne humaine et ça c'est vraiment
inacceptable donc oui il va y avoir des
des manifestations plus nombreuses
il roule deux gouvernements de trouver
des solutions mais les choix qu'il fait
on voit que ça va aggraver les
difficultés d un certain nombre de
français les retraités les personnes qui
s'occupent des épaules par notamment
merci jean claude husson d'être venu en
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes co
secrétaire départemental du coup du
parti socialiste et maire aussi de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines merci à vous
et bon week-end
les étudiants justement nous en parlions
jeudi il manifesté contre la nouvelle
plateforme parcours sub pour l'entrée à
l'université à l'appel de plusieurs
syndicats dont l'unef les étudiants se
sont rassemblés à paris pour cette
nouvelle plateforme qui remplace
l'ancienne apb ne sera pas plus efficace
on les écoute on écoute le représentant
du syndicat unef au sein de l'ue vs qu à
nous on a une seule chose à dire c'est
ni tirage au sort ni sélection si elle
est du tirage au sort auparavant c'était
une aberration mais si elle avait lieu
ce que l'état n'investit pas assez dans
l'enseignement supérieur et qui a pas
assez de places dans les fleurs à
l'heure actuelle la sélection elle va
pas du tout régler ce problème il y aura
toujours pas assez de place sauf que les
étudiants auront encore moins accès aux
études de leur choix devant nous ce
qu'on dit c'est ni tirage au sort ni
sélection investissement massif d'un
lancement supérieure elle lundi
l'établissement lépine versailles a été
inauguré une plateforme de services
gérontologique de 112 lits porté par une
société coopérative d'intérêt collectif
cette collaboration privé public dans ce
domaine est une première en france les
détails avec marylène ya piccino patrick
jacques de dixmude et quentin le frère
le projet date de 2011
un établissement qui répond à une
demande grandissante versailles compte
en tout cinq ehpad son territoire les
plus de 75 ans représentent 10% de la
population
l'idée plutôt que de moderniser un
établissement vétuste créer un nouveau
projet dans une dynamique de
collaboration entre acteurs du soin aux
personnes âgées
on retrouve fait la réunification de 2
et pat deux établissements qui étaient
distincts dans des bâtiments distincts
et on a rapatrié également le service de
soins infirmiers à domicile qui était
derrière la mairie auparavant
l'initiative est une première en france
la ville s'est associée à entreprendre
pour humaniser la dépendance une
structure membre de l'association
habitat et humanisme
ensemble ils ont lancé une société
coopérative d'intérêt collectif
un partenariat public privé dans le
secteur du sanitaire et sociale pour
lever 1 million d'euros de fonds la
population a pu prendre part au projet
est réalisé un investissement solidaire
et fiscalement intéressants et on
travaille sur une approche
à partir de laquelle chacun sent qu'en
fait ce qu'il est content pour le
résultat qui est recherché c'est à dire
finalement le soin et le prendre soin
des personnes qui sont accueillis lépine
versailles intervient sur trois pôles
différents un service de soins
infirmiers à domicile dont une partie de
l'équipe et spécialisée alzheimer un
accueil de jour avec des activités
adaptées et une partie hébergement avec
112 lits occupés par des résidents
depuis décembre dernier ils sont en
formation barman au lycée d'hôtellerie
de guyancourt et ont mis en avant leur
technique et leur créativité
mercredi sept élèves vont tenter de se
qualifier pour un concours international
de création de cocktails à base de
calvados en alcool qu'il devait associer
un légume
aurélie rose a suivi le concours
reportage geste précis et concentration
pour ces élèves du lycée d'hôtellerie de
guyancourt qui tente de décrocher leur
place pour un concours international de
création de cocktails
un trophée qui s'adresse aussi bien aux
barmen professionnels qu'aux élèves
ils sont notamment jugés sur leur
technique on doit exécuter de telle ou
telle façon il faut bien au niveau du
shaker au niveau 2 de son matériel etc
il ya beaucoup de respect de règles à
suivre il faut suivre ces règles pour
que tout fonctionne correctement
autre critère pour s'imposer le goût le
cocktail doit obligatoirement contenir
un alcool le calvados aime également
imposé cette année les légumes
l'apparence la rom ou encore la
décoration sont scrutés à la loupe pour
moi celui ci manque d'équilibré ils ont
bien compris le thème de cette année qui
était
légumes mais eux
celui ci est
le légume prend bien trop le dessus par
rapport au calvados et l' équilibre
n'est pas au bout d'une heure et demie
le verdict tombe c'est mathilde et son
cocktail pink même à base de sirop de
vanille de jus de pommes de calvados et
de jus de betterave qui obtient le plus
de points en fait elle me faisait penser
une une fake mais quand quand j'étais
petit et inside justement il y avait de
la pomme et de la betterave et du cou
et puis la couleur est sympa donc je me
suis point comptable ça pourrait être
bien fin mars
l'étudiante défendra les couleurs de
guyancourt lors de la finale nationale à
quoi
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo ce
week-end vous retrouvez le 7 8 dossiers
sur les cultures urbaines dans les
yvelines retour de l'actualité en direct
lundi à 18h sur l'antenne de tv 78 d'ici
là restez connectés et informés grâce à
notre site internet et nos réseaux
sociaux tv 78 bons gagnent à tous et à
la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
pour